new research shows many black and Latino
owned businesses are really struggling
to get financial help during this
pandemic according to a survey
commissioned by the equal rights groups
almost two-thirds of minority business
owners say they were denied stimulus
loans or they're still waiting for an
answer at O'Keefe is following this
story in Washington and joins us with
more on that
Edie what you find good to see you good
to see you Gail good morning we'll look
minorities continued to be hardest hit
by the corona virus and now they're also
struggling with the economic impact
african-american and Latino business
owners struggling to find access to
federal assistance and many of them tell
us that might mean they have to shut
down for good it is being seems like
just a runaround a complete runaround
Sean Etta Foust applied for a paycheck
protection loan way back on April 4th
for her Charlotte based company faithful
Moving & Storage this is our only source
of income so so that we could still
maintain the lifestyle that we live or
something honest with you last week her
bank said she'd been approved for a
$42,000 loan but this week she received
a $7,500 deposit with no explanation
leaving her frustrated say hurt like
we're not equal to it's a lot of
different emotions that runs through
your head when you when you see that up
front or when you hear that hey because
I wasn't this established or had this
type of relationship with with my bank
then my application was funded through
for someone else Faust is not alone a
new survey found just 12 percent of
African American and Latino business
owners received the federal assistance
they applied for and just 38 percent
received any aid at all nationwide
nearly half of businesses have received
some help black Latino businesses do not
have access to capital and the
relationships with our banking system
the way the mainstream business
community does Rafael koyasu helped run
the
for Unidos us why don't they have good
relationships with banks 70% of Latino
businesses start with on personal
savings so for many times this was the
first time that many businesses you've
been fairly successful businesses in our
community had to engage a bank in
applying for a loan so the relationships
aren't there Congress directed the Small
Business Administration to prioritize
underserved communities including
minority and women-owned businesses but
the SBA's watchdog recently found the
agency did not provide guidance to
lenders on how to do that and
recommended SBA begin collecting
demographic information to track the
disparity a lot of minority-owned
businesses are negating access to the
Paycheck protection program as we in
Congress intended in a virtual hearing
this week senators urged the Treasury
secretary and the chairman of the
Federal Reserve to do more small and
minority businesses are the lifeblood in
those small rural communities not big
corporation money
Andreea po had never taken out a loan
for her hair and makeup business in
Atlanta and she thinks that's one reason
she was denied funds by the SBA they
want you to have a relationship with the
bank you couldn't even walk into a bank
I don't have a relationship I used to
have relationships with people so I just
I just feel like that was the crotch
that was a big crack this week former
NBA star Magic Johnson announced plans
to launch his own loan program directly
for minority-owned small businesses and
while some big companies are getting
millions of dollars in federal
assistance the companies that who need
owes us and their partners a color of
change spoke to say they're looking for
just $50,000 or less to stay afloat Gail
well it's got to be tough to think
you're getting 42,000 and the check
comes in at 7,500 that's a big
difference thank you very much